hey everyone i welcome you all to this
puppet full course by simply learn
in this complete course we will learn
everything that we need to know
to excel in puppet we have mathifs and
anjali to guide us through this journey
we should begin with having a basic
understanding of puppet
after that we shall have a look at its
relevance in the present scenario
then we will learn about the different
aspects of puppet like price
architecture and community we shall
understand the puppet concepts with the
help of a hands-on demo
after we have a fair amount of knowledge
regarding the puppet we will look into
the interview questions to increase our
chances of tracking any devops interview
so before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget
to click that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
so our first topic for the session is
what is puppet
hello this is matthew from simply learn
and today we're going to continue our
education in devops and we're going to
focus specifically on
puppet so in this session what we're
going to do is we're going to cover
what and why you would use puppets what
are the different elements and
components of puppet and how does it
actually work
and then we'll look into the companies
that are adopting puppet and what are
the advantages that they have now
received by having puppet within their
organization
and finally we'll wrap things up by
reviewing how you can actually write a
manifest
in puppet so let's get started so why
puppet
so here is a scenario that as an
administrator you may already be
familiar with you as an administrator
have
multiple servers that you have to work
with and manage
so what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it
but what if the scenario changes and you
have
multiple servers going down so here is
where puppet
shows its strap with puppets all you
have to do is write a simple
script that can be written with ruby and
write out and deploy
to the servers your settings for each of
those servers
the code gets pushed out and to the
servers that are
having problems and then you can choose
to either roll back to those servers to
their previous working states
or set them to a new state and do all of
this
in a matter of seconds and it doesn't
matter how
large your server environment is you can
reach to
all of these servers your environment is
secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this
all through infrastructure as code which
is the advanced
devops model for building out solutions
so let's dig deeper into what puppet
actually is so
puppet is a configuration management
tool
maybe similar tools like chef that you
may already be familiar with it ensures
that all your systems are configured
to a desired and predictable state
public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software
automatically you can deploy your
software to all of your systems or to
specific
systems and this is all done with code
this means you can test the environment
and you can have a guarantee
that the environment you want is written
and deployed
accurately so let's go through those
components of
puppet so here we have a breakdown of
the puppet environment and on
the top we have the main server
environment and then below that we have
the client environment
that would be installed on each of the
servers that would be running within
your network
so if we look at the top part of the
screen we have here our
puppet master store which has and
contains our main configuration files
and those are comprised of manifests
that are actual codes for configuring
the clients
we have templates that combine our codes
together
to render a final document and you have
files that will be deployed as content
that could be potentially downloaded by
the clients wrapping this all together
is a
module of manifest templates and files
you would apply
a certificate authority to sign the
actual document
so that the clients actually know that
they're receiving the appropriate
and authorized modules outside
of the master server where you'd create
your manifest templates and files
you would have public client is a piece
of software that is used to configure
a specific machine there are two parts
to the client
one is the agent that constantly
interacts with the
master server to ensure that the
certificates are being
updated appropriately and then you have
the fact of it the current state of the
client
that is used and communicated back to
through the agent
so let's step through the workings of
puppet so
the puppet environment is a master slave
architecture the clients themselves are
distributed across your network
and they are constantly communicating
back to a master server environment
where you have your puppet modules
the client agent sends a certificate
with the id of that server back to the
master and then the master will then
sign that certificate and send it back
to the client
and this authentication allows for a
secure and verifiable communication
between client and master the factor
then collects the state of the client
and sends that
to the master based on the facts sent
back the master then compiles manifests
into the catalogs and those catalogs are
sent back to the clients
and an agent on the client will then
initiate
the catalog a report is generated by the
client that describes any changes
that have been made and sends that back
to the master
with the goal here of ensuring that the
master has full
understanding of the hardware running
software in your network this process is
repeated at regular intervals ensuring
all kind systems
are up to date so let's have a look at
companies that
are using puppet today there are a
number of companies that have
adopted puppet as a way to manage their
infrastructure so companies that are
using puppy today
include spotify google att
so why are these companies choosing to
use puppet as their main configuration
management tool the answer can be seen
if we look at a specific company
staples so staples chose to take and use
puppet for their configuration
management tool
and use it within their own private
cloud the results
were dramatic the amount of time that
the it organization
was able to save in deploying and
managing
their infrastructure through using
puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow to
experiment with
other and new projects and assignments
a real tangible benefit to a company so
let's look at how you write a manifest
in
puppet so so manifests are designed for
writing out
in code how you would configure a
specific
node in your server environment the
manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then
executed on the client each of the
manifests are written
in the language of ruby with a dot pp
extension
if we step through the five key steps
for writing a manifest they are
one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator
two compile your manifest is compiled
into a
catalog three deploy the catalog is then
deployed onto the clients
four execute the catalogs are run on the
client
by the agent and then five end
clients are configured to a specific and
desired
state if we actually look into how
manifest is written
it's written with a very common syntax
if you've done any work with
ruby or really configuration of systems
in the past this may look very familiar
to you so we
break out the work that we have here you
start off with a package
file or service as your resource type
and then you give it a name
and then you look at the features that
need to be said such as ip address then
you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the manifest can contain multiple
resource types
if we continue to write our manifest and
puppet the default keyword applies a
manifest to
all clients so an example would be to
create a file path
that creates a folder called sample in a
main folder called etc the specified
content is written
into a file that is then posted into
that folder
and then we're going to say we want to
be able to trigger an apache service
and then ensure that that apache service
is installed on a node
so we write the manifest and we deploy
it to a client machine
on that client machine a new folder will
be created with a file
in that folder and an apache server will
be installed
you can do this to any machine and
you'll have exactly
the same results on those machines
this is anjali from simply learn and
today i'll be showing you the
installation procedure for the
configuration management tool puppet
so what exactly is the use of puppet if
you consider the scenario of an
organization which has a very large
infrastructure
it's required that all the systems and
servers in this infrastructure
is continuously maintained at a desired
state this is where puppet comes in
puppet automates this entire procedure
thus reducing the manual work
so before we move on to the demo let me
tell you what the architecture of puppet
looks like
so puppet has two main components you
have the puppet master
and the puppet client the puppet master
is where you write the configuration
files and store them and the puppet
client are basically those client
machines
which require the configuration in case
of puppet
these configuration files that you write
are called manifests
so let's move on to the demo so here are
my two machines
the first is the server system which is
basically a master where you'll write
your configuration files and the others
the node or the client system
so let's have a look at both of these
machines this my node system the
terminals open here
and the terminal has a black background
with white text
and as of my server or the master
machine it has a black background with
green text
so we started a server machine the first
thing that we need to do is we need to
remove the firewall
so in a lot of cases there are chances
that the firewall stops the connection
between your server and your node now
since i'm doing a demo
and i'm just showing you how puppet
works between two virtual boxes
i can safely remove the firewall without
any worries
but when you're implementing puppet in
an organization
or a number of systems on a local
network be careful about the
consequences of doing so
so our firewall is disabled next thing
that we do is we'll change the hostname
of our server system now while using the
puppet tool it's always advisable that
you name your server's host
as puppet this because the puppet tool
identifies the hostname puppet by
default as the host name for the master
or the server system
let's just check if the host name is
changed successfully
yup so that's done so as you see still
local host is appearing as the host name
so just close your terminal and start it
again
and you see here the hostname has been
changed to puppet
okay so the next thing that we have to
do is we install our puppet labs
make sure your system is connected to
the net
right so puppet labs is installed next
we need to
install the puppet server service on our
server system
now that our puppet server service is
installed
we need to move into the system
configurations for our puppet server
so the path for that is etc
sysconfig puppet server
so this is a configuration file for the
puppet server
now if you come down to this line now
this line here
this is the line which allocates memory
for your puppet server now you must
remember
that puppet is a very resource extensive
tool
so just in case to ensure that we do not
encounter any errors because of
out of memory we will reduce these sizes
so as of now we have 2 gb allocated by
default we'll change this to 512 mb
now in a lot of cases it may work
without doing so
but just to be on the safer side we make
this change
save it and go back to your terminal
we are now ready to start our puppet
server service
the first time you start your puppet
server service it may take a while
next we need to enable this
and if your puppet server service is
started and enabled successfully this is
the output that you would get
in case you're still not sure you can
always check the status
at any point of time and as you see here
it's active
so everything's fine as of now next
thing we do is we'll move on to our
agent system
or our client or node system
so here too we'll have to install puppet
labs but before we do so we need to make
a small change in our hosts file so
let's open the host file
yeah so this is a host file we need to
add a single line here
which specifies our puppet master so
first we put our puppet masters ip
address followed by the host name
and then we'll add a dns for our puppet
server so let's just go back
to our server system and find out its ip
address
and that's my ip address for the server
system
now the host name of our puppet server
and a dns for it
save this file and return to your
terminal
so now we can download our puppet labs
on the node
system is the exact same procedure that
you followed for downloading puppet labs
on your server system too
so in my note system the puppet labs is
already downloaded so the next thing
is we need to install a puppet agent
service
so puppet is a pull type of
configuration tool what this means is
that all your
configuration files that you'll be
writing on your server is pulled by the
node system as and when it requires it
so this is the co-functionality of the
agent service which is installed on your
client
node or agent system so my puppet agent
service is
installed so next i'll just check if my
puppet server is reachable from this
node system so 8140 is a port number
that the puppet server must be listening
on
and it's connected to puppet so that
guarantees that your server is reachable
from the node system
so now that everything is configured
right we can start our agent service
so guys you would have noticed that the
command for starting the agent service
is a little more complex in the command
for starting your server service
this is because when you start your
agent service you're not just starting a
service but you're also creating a
certificate
this is the certificate that will be
sent over to your master system
now at the master system there's
something called the certificate
authority this gives the master the
rights to sign a certificate
if it agrees to share information with
that particular node so let's execute
this command
which does both the function of sending
the certificate
and starting your agent service so as
you can see here
our services started successfully it's
in a running state
now we'll move to our master system or
the server system
so first we'll have a look at the
certificates that we received
the certificate should be in this
location
so as you can see here this is the
certificate that we just received from
our agent service
so this here within quotes is the name
of our certificate
so next when we are signing the
certificate this is the name we'll
provide to specify that this is the
particular certificate that we want to
sign so the minute we sign a certificate
the note
that send the certificate gets a
notification that the master has
accepted your request so after this we
can begin sharing
our manifest files now here's the
command for signing this certificate
okay so our certificate is signed which
means that the
notes request is approved and the minute
the certificate is signed
the request is removed from this list so
now if we execute the same command
as we did to check the list of all the
certificates we will not find the
certificate anymore
let's just check that so as you see now
there are no more requests pending
because we have
accepted all the requests if you want to
have a look at all the certificates that
is signed or
unsigned you can use the same command
with the addition of
all and all the certificates received so
far will be listed
as you can see here the plus sign
indicates that the certificate request
has already been accepted
so now that our certificate is signed
the next thing we do
is we'll create a sample manifest file
so this is the path that you create your
manifest files in
our file name is sample.pp and our files
created
so right now we have no content in this
file we'll just check if the agent is
receiving it
and once that's confirmed we'll add some
content to the file so let's move to our
agent system
now this is the command to execute at
the agent system to pull your
configuration files
so a catalog is applied in 0.02 seconds
so now that the communication between
our agent system
and our master system is working
perfectly fine
let's add some content to the previous
placeholder file that we created on our
master system
so now we open the same file in an
editor
okay so we are going to write a code for
installing the httpd package
on our node system which is basically
your apache service
node and then within quotes insert the
host name of your note system
so my node systems host name is client
the package you wish to install which in
our case is httpd
and the action to be performed
and that's it a very small and simple
code save this file
now let's go back to our node system and
let's pull the second version of the
same configuration file so every time
you execute this command as we did
previously to
what happens is the agent service so the
agent service basically checks on your
master system
if there's any new configuration file
added or if there's any change to the
previous configuration file made
if so then the catalog is applied once
again so now our catalogue is applied in
1.55 seconds
so now to check if our catalog served
its purpose
let's just open our browser just type
localhost here
and as you can see if your httpd package
has been successfully installed the
apache testing page will appear here so
we come to an
end of our installation and
configuration of the configuration
management tool puppet
now let's have a look at the pricing
model for puppet the most popular
version and the most widely used
version is puppet open source so it's
freely available and there are packages
available on app.puppetlabs
or yum.puppetlabs.com and these are free
to install and free for life
the only downside is you don't get any
support then you have to update it
manually
the enterprise version is available for
a price depending on the size of your
organization
and you have to get a quote from puppet
labs the enterprise version
has extra features but they're only
required for an interface
class setup looking at the architecture
puppet is pretty much a client server
architecture
the clients communicate with the puppet
server or ssl
so you need to have self-signed ssl
certificates because
obviously you're not going to buy
certificates for your internal
communication
the certificate is signed by the puppet
server certificate authority
so puppet internally packs a certificate
authority
now which you can utilize to sign
certificates from the client
so when the initial installation takes
place you have to assign all of your
clients
you can set puppet on auto signing mode
but that's not really safe on the client
side you've got the agent running
all the puppet clients and factors so
factor is an
information collector that sends
information from all the clients to the
server
puppet agent is the agent that
communicates continuously with the
puppet server
you can set up an interval for
communication of the puppet agent with
the server
on the server side you've got a lot of
things you've got environments
so you can have multiple environments
managed by a single puppet server
those are basically defined on a
directory layer and you've got
the etc puppet labs environments folder
where you can define
environments you've got in build
certificate authority
which allows you to have a signing
authority which assigns all the
certificates of the clients
only after which the clients can talk to
the puppet server you have manifests
templates modules and files which we
will talk about in the next slide
now basically the manifest is the actual
code which configures the client
the modules are full-fledged bundles
which include manifests templates and
files
templates are configuration files which
are created on the fly
based on the client configuration so
let's say there's an apache server
you want to configure the apache.coms
will be saved as
a template inside the module then there
are files which
are static files say you want to serve
out the index.html as a static file
on your apache servers you can store
that inside the files folder
inside your module now let's have a look
at the puppet community
the puppet community is a rich community
of a lot of people
officially there is no count but
counting the various channels where
people collaborate there are a little
over 2 900 committers to github
projects who are directly or indirectly
associated with puppet labs
there are 4893 modules on the official
puppet forge
these include modules from the puppet
labs and also from open source
contributors to github
so that's nearly five thousand modules
of ready-made code available on the
puppet forge
so before you write any code for puppet
you can check to see if it's already
been written by someone
now there's a mailing list which has 6
588 participants
apart from this on slack overflow you
have a big tag of puppet labs and puppet
which gives you a list of only puppet
questions that's a good playground for
you to interact with people who are
already using puppet
and who are contributing and helping
others now let's have a look at puppet
forge
so puppet forge is a github client for a
repository which is hosted by puppet
labs
that has almost 5000 modules of puppet
code so
these are both puppet labs and community
contributed
the best thing about this is that
they're easy to customize
so when you have a requirement for
anything you're doing with your
infrastructure
you can just grab one of those five 5000
modules and then you can customize it
according to your needs
one of the other benefits is they have
built-in tests so they
follow all of the best practices now if
you write your own module
you also have to write your own tests
and you have to spend extra time writing
best practice code
all of that has been taken care of and
you can just download any one of those
and customize it according to your needs
and you're good to go
so that's the benefit you get from such
a large community where people
contribute to the modules and the code
and
share with the community the puppet dsl
puppet dsl is a puppet domain specific
language
it's the puppet's primary programming
language it's just like plain english
and you don't really need to be a
programmer to write code in it
it's kind of a sub child of ruby because
it approaches and uses is equal to and
greater than marks to define things
so it's very easy to learn you can
specify packages that you want to
install
you can specify services to be managed
you can do things based on the operating
system you have
so we'll be writing a small puppet
module which will be using this
puppet dsl we will do that after we
install the puppet server and the client
and then we will write a simple puppet
module to show how to use the puppet dsl
let's have a look at the demo we are
going to do so you will be
setting up the machines using pseudodns
because we want to have a resolvable dns
because only by having a resolvable dns
can we use puppet because
puppet uses the ssl certificates now
we'll be installing the puppet server
and the client
will be signing the certificates of the
client on the server side
and then we'll proceed with writing an
ntp module which we'll be using for
installation of ntp on the client
and then we'll look at the puppet
programming language or dsl
now we're going to look at a demo here
so we will be setting up the machines
we'll set up a
pseudo dns locally because puppet
requires a fully qualified domain name
in order to run
since there is a certificate
communication taking place here
we will be installing the puppet server
the puppet client
will be signing the certificate and
finally we will write an ntp
module and make it run
so now we will be starting a puppet
master and a client
i have two machines here one is the
puppet master and the second is the
puppet client
the puppet master has got almost 4 gig
of ram and 4 v
cpus which i can show you here
because it's a ruby on rails application
it requires a lot of cpu and ram
for the client i don't need that much
ram and cpu so i've allotted one
gigabyte of ram and one vcpu
i will start both of these machines and
find out the ip addresses
right click normal start
both of these machines are starting up
the puppet client has started up and the
first thing i'll do is log in using root
and red hat password
and then i will change the host name so
i'll say vim
etc hostname this will open a hostname
file in a text editor which is
vim then we'll do a dd
which will delete that existing host
name
and then i press the i for insert mode
and finally i'll type
the puppet hyphen client
which will be the host name of this
machine i'll save this file by doing
escape
semicolon wq exclamation mark
and i'll reboot the machine
similarly going to the puppet master
i'll say root red hat
i'll open the hostname file
say dd then i'll say puppet hyphen
master
i'll save this file and reboot the
machine for the hostname change to take
effect
the hostname change does not take effect
unless you reboot the machine
now both of these machines are ready i'm
going to find
out the ips and use the mac terminal to
log into these
so this is uh 23 and 21 so 23 is my
server and 21 is my client
i'll ssh to 23 first
now in order for the puppet master to be
installed i need a fully qualified
domain name here
and a fake dns which means a fully
resolvable dns name
so if i do hostname here you see my host
name is puppetmaster
in order to set up a fake dns i need to
go to the etc hosts file
go to the end then i say ip address
host name local then space host name
now this is one of the techniques which
makes the linux server believe that
there's a fully qualified domain name on
this machine
i'll save this
then i do a hostname hyphen f you see
it has a fully qualified domain name now
so now we will be downloading the puppet
labs repository for ubuntu 16.04 which
is
xenial so i'll say curl hyphen
0 https
dot
apt.puppetlabs.com
slash puppet labs hyphen release
hyphen pc1 hyphensenial.dab
you can see there is a debian file which
has been downloaded here i will import
this using the dpkg command
so i'll say dpkg hyphen i puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc1
hyphensenial.dap
and then i'll say apt-get update which
will update my apt package indexes on
this machine
and now i'll install the puppet server
so i'll say apt-get
install puppet hyphen puppet server
hyphen wide
so the puppet server is now installed
and we will be configuring the memory
allocation for the puppet server
so i'll say etc default puppet server
so by default it has only
got two gigabyte allocated we'll give it
three gigabyte because it's jvm
i'll make this three and i'll change
this to three as well
and i'll save this file
i'll make sure the unconfigured firewall
allows port 8140 which is the puppet lab
puppet server port the rules have been
updated to allow that
i'll now start the puppet server so i'll
say a system ctl
start puppet server
it takes some time because it's jvm so
it takes a couple of minutes to start
the puppet server
so the puppet server is now running i'll
also
enable it at boot time so i'll say
systemctl
enable puppet to server
it will enable it boot time now i also
need to configure a fully qualified
domain name here so okay
so i'll do that by going into the hosts
file
i'll go to the end and i'll say
192.168.1.23 and then puppet
hyphen dot local and then puppet hyphen
server
if i do a hostname hyphen f
put hyphen master.local because the
current hostname is
puppet hyphen master so the trick is to
have the hostname.local in front of the
ip address
in the host file
having a fully qualified domain name now
now we will go
to the client setup the client setup is
almost the same
with just a small difference the package
which we need to install on the client
is puppet agent so we will go to the
client
so you see this has got a host name now
we also need to set up
the fake dns here so i'll copy this
hostname
open the host line go to the end
write the ip address
and then dot local and then host name
again
so this will give me a fully qualified
domain name so when i do a host name
it says puppet hyphen client when i do a
host name
hyphen f it says puppet client local to
install the puppet agent on this machine
i will need to download the zenio
packages
so i'll say wget https
app.puppetlabs.com slash puppet labs
hyphen release hyphen pc1 hyphen
xenial.deb
i'll download this and then i'll say
dpkg hyphen
i puppet labs iphone release hyphen pc1
hyphensenial.dap
so this is the repository package which
i'll be downloading here
and then i'll say apt get update hyphen
y
this will update my apt caches on this
machine
and now i'll finally install the puppet
agent
so i'll say apt-get install puppet agent
hyphen agent hyphen y
now the puppet agent is here i'll start
the puppet agent
and i'll enable it at boot time so i'll
say system control
start puppet then system control
enable puppet
now puppet is enabled now we have set up
the fully qualified domain name on the
client and the server
but each of them should know each other
so we'll have to do a cross certificate
host mapping
so we will be copying the host file
entry of the client
and adding it to the server so i'll go
to the etc hosts on the server side
go to the end paste it there okay
and i'll be adding the entry of the
master on the client side
okay now both of the servers will
recognize each other now
because one of them has the host entry
of the other
so if i do from the master ping puppet
hyphen
agent.local
if i ping the agent from the server
hyphen client.local it is able to ping
it
and if i ping the master from the client
if i say ping puppet hyphenmaster.local
both of them will be able to ping each
other
now the next step would be to create a
certificate signing request
so i'll go to my to this directory which
is opt puppet labs puppet bin
and i'll say puppet agent hyphen t
hyphen knife and server
is equal to and i'll give the fully
qualified domain name of the puppet
master
then i'll say hyphen f
when i do this it will create a
certificate signing request you see
now if i go to the server and i do an
opt
i'll check and see how many certificates
are pending to be signed
you'll see there is a puppet client
certificate which is pending to be
signed
which is denoted by the absence of a
plus sign here
i'll be signing the certificate so i'll
say puppet search sign
and then the name so puppet hyphen
client
dot local this will sign the
certificates and when i go to the server
on the client side if i run the puppet
agent again
you see it's actually pulling down the
catalog as of now it has an empty
catalog
that says there is nothing
now we have configured the puppet agent
and the master now we will be taking a
module from puppet forge
puppet forge is a big collection of open
source modules which are free to use
as a first step we will be using a
ready-made module
and that would be a demonstration for
how to actually get up and running with
a module so
search for apache module here
this is the puppet labs apache module
i'll be using the puppet command line
puppet module install
this is the command for that but i will
make sure i run this command from the
puppet home
so i'll go to the master i'll go to etc
puppet labs
code environments production in this
i'll do modules
now i will run it from the binary which
is present at the opt puppet labs bin
puppet
and then module install puppet labs
hyphen apache
and then this version so we are
specifying the latest version
and i'll hit enter when i press enter it
starts downloading from the
forge api so you see the module is
downloaded
in addition to the dependencies so there
is concat stdlib and apache
so now i'll go to a folder here which is
one level up called manifest
so this is the file here etc puppet labs
code environments production manifest
so in this there's a file which i'll be
creating called site.pp
the site.pp will specify and this is the
main controller of how the
infrastructure looks
in the site pp i specify
that i want puppetclient.localnode to
have the apache module included
i'll save this file and the only thing i
need to do now
is since all is set on the server side i
need to go to the client side and run
puppet agent it will automatically
download the apache module
and compile it and it may then make sure
the server is in a state
so when i press enter we see a lot of
output it tries to configure apache on
this machine
and done now when i go to the front end
of this machine
on this port i should be able to see
apache's default page
so this is apaches default page so the
module which we downloaded from
the forge was actually written in a way
that apache would be installed and run
at boot time
so that is why it's running here and
that is
all we have from the uh puppet module
and this concludes the demo today we're
going to go through a
real tough battle we're going to decide
which is better for your operations
environment is it
chef puppet antipole or salt stank
all four are going to go head to head so
let's go through the scenario of why
you'd want to use these tools so
let's meet tim he's our system
administrator and tim is
a happy camper putting and working on
all of the
systems in his network but what happens
if
a system fails if there's a fire a
server goes down
well tim knows exactly what to do he can
fix that fire
really easily the problems become really
difficult for tim however
if multiple servers start failing
particularly when you have
large and expanding networks so
this is why tim really needs to have a
configuration management tool
and we need to now decide what would be
the best tool
for him because configuration management
tools can help
make tim look like a superstar
all he has to do is configure the right
codes
that allows him to push out the
instructions on how to
set up each of the servers quickly
effectively
and at scale all right let's go through
the tools and see which ones we can use
the tools that we're going to go through
are chef puppet
and support and salt stacks and we have
videos on most of these
software and services that you can go
and view to get an
overview or a deep dive in how those
products work
so let's go and get to know our
contestants so our first contestant
is chef and chef is a tool that allows
you to
configure very large environments it
allows you to scale very effectively
across the entire
ecosystem and infrastructure chef is by
default an open source
code and one of the things that you find
is a consistent metaphor for the tools
that we recommend on simplylearn
is to use open source code the code
itself is actually written
in language of ruby and erlang and it's
really
designed for heterogeneous
infrastructures that are looking for a
mature
solution the way that chef works is that
you write
recipes that are compiled into cookbooks
and those
cookbooks are the definition of how you
would set up
a node and a node is a selection
of servers that you have configured in a
specific way so for instance you may
have
apache linux servers running or you may
have a my
sql server running or you may have a
python server running
and chef is able to communicate back and
forth between the nodes
to understand what nodes are being
impacted and
need to have instructions sent out to
them to correct that impact
you can also send instructions from the
server to
the nodes to make a significant update
or a minor update
so there's great communication going
back and forth if we look at the pros
and cons
the pros for chef is that there is a
significant
following for chef and that has resulted
in a very large collection of
recipes that allow you to be able to
quickly stand up environments there's no
need for you to have to
learn complex recipes the first thing
you should do is go out and find the
recipes that are available
it integrates with git really well and
provides for
really good strong version control some
of the consoles
are really around the learning speed it
takes to go from
beginner user with chef to being an
expert there is a considerable amount of
learning that has to take place
and it's compounded by having to learn
ruby
as the programming language and the main
server itself doesn't really have a
whole lot of control
it's really dependent on the
communication throughout the whole
network
all right let's look at our second
contender
puppet and puppet is actually in many
ways very
similar to chef there are some
differences but again
puppet is designed to be able to support
very large heterogeneous organization
it is also built with ruby and uses dsl
for writing manifests
so there are some strong similarities
here to
chef as with a chef there is a master
slave
infrastructure with puppet and you have
a master server that has
the manifests that you put together in a
single catalog and those catalogs are
then
pushed out to the clients of an ssl
connection
some of the pros with uh puppet is that
as with chef there is a
really strong community around puppies
and
there's just a great amount of
information and support that you can get
right out of the gate it is a very well
developed
reporting mechanism that makes it easier
for you as an
administrator to be able to understand
your infrastructure
one of the cons is that you have to
really be good at learning ruby again as
with chef
you know the more advanced tasks really
need to have
those ruby skills and as with chef the
server
also doesn't have much control so let's
look at our third contender here
ansible and so ansible is slightly
different it is
the way the ansible works is that it
actually just pushes
out the instructions to the server
environment there isn't a client
server or master slave environment
where ansible would be communicating
backwards and forwards with its
infrastructure it is merely going to
push that
instructions out the good news is that
the instructions are written in yaml and
yowell stands for
yaml 8 markup language yaml is actually
pretty easy to learn if you know xml and
xml is pretty easy
if you know xml you're going to get yamo
really well
ansible does work very well on
environments where the focus is getting
servers up and running
really fast it's very very responsive
and can allow you to
move quickly to get your infrastructure
up quick very fast and
we're talking seconds and minutes here
really really quick
so again the way that ansible works is
that you put together a playbook and an
inventory or
you have a playbook so the way that
ansible works is that you have a
playbook and the playbook
it then goes against the inventory of
servers and will push out the
instructions for that playbook
to those servers so some of the pros
that we have for ansible
we don't need to have an agent installed
on the remote nodes and servers it makes
it easier for the configuration
yaml is really easy to learn you can get
up to speed
and get very proficient with yamo
quickly the actual performance once you
actually have your infrastructure
up and running is less than other tools
that we have on our list now
i do have to add a proviso this is a
relative less
it's still very fast it's going to be a
lot faster than
individuals manually standing up servers
but it's just not as fast as some of the
other tools that we have on this list
and yaml itself as a language while it's
easy to learn it's not as
powerful as ruby ruby will allow you to
do
things that at an advanced level that
you can't do
easily with the ammo so let's look at
our final contender here
salt stack so sort stack is a cli
based tool it means that you will have
to get your
command line tools out or your terminal
window out so you can actually
manage the entire environment via salt
sac the instructions themselves
are based on python but you can actually
write them in yammer
or dsl which is really convenient
and as a product it's really designed
for environments that want to
scale quickly and be very resilient
now the way that sort snap works is that
you have a master environment that
pushes out the instructions
to what they call grains which is your
network
and so let's step through some of the
pros and cons that we have here
with saltstag so sourcetec is very easy
to use
once it's up and running it has a really
good reporting mechanism that makes
your job as an operator in your devops
environment
much much easier the actual setup
though is a little bit tougher than some
of the other tools and and it's getting
easier with the newer releases but it's
just a little bit tougher
and related to that is that saltstack is
fairly late in the game when it comes to
actually having
a graphical user interface for being
able to create
and manage your environment other tools
such as ansible have actually had a ui
environment for quite some time all
right so we've gone through
all four tools let's see how they all
stack up
next to each other so let the race begin
let's start with the first stage
architecture so the architecture for
most
of our environments is a server client
environment so for chef puppet and salt
snack so very
similar architecture there the one
exception is ansible
which is a client only solution so
you're pushing out the instructions from
a server and pushing them out into your
network and there isn't a
client environment that there isn't a
two-way communication
back to that main client for what's
actually happening in your network
so let's talk about the next stage ease
of setup
so we look at the four tools there is
one tool that really stands out
for ease of setup and that is ansible it
is going to be the easiest tool for you
to set up and if you're new to having
these types of tools in your environment
you may want to start with ansible just
to try out
and see how easy it is to create
automated configuration
before looking at other tools now and so
with that said
chef puppet and source tech aren't that
hard to set up either and you'll find
there's
actually some great instructions on how
to do that setup in the online community
let's talk about the languages that you
can use in your configuration
so we have two different types of
language with both chef and ansible
being procedural
in that they actually specify at how you
actually supposed to do
the task in your instructions with
puppet and sword stack it's
decorative where you specify only what
to do
in the instructions let's talk about
scalability
which tools scale the most effectively
and as you can imagine
all of these tools are designed for
scalability
that is the driver for these kind of
tools you want them to be able to scale
to
massive organizations what do the
management tools look like for our four
contenders
so again we have a two-way split with
ansible and sort stack the management
tools are
really easy to use you're gonna love
using them they're just
fantastic to use with puppet and chef
the
management tools are much harder to
learn and they do require
that you learn some either the puppet
dsl or the ruby dsl to be able to be a
true master
in that environment but what does
interoperability look like
again as you'd imagine with the similar
to scalability
interoperability with these products is
very high
in all four cases now let's talk about
cloud availability this is increasingly
becoming
more important for organizations as they
move rapidly onto cloud services
well both ansible and softstack have a
big fail here
neither of them are available in the
most popular cloud environments
and puppet and chef are actually
available in both amazon
and azure now we've actually just
haven't had a chance to update our
chef link here but chef is now available
on
azure as well as amazon so what does
communication look like with all of our
four
tools so the communication is slightly
different with them chef has its own
knife tool and whereas puppet uses ssl
to secure sockets layer
and ansible and saltsec use secure
socket hashing and ssh
as their communication tool bottom line
all four
tools are very secure in their
communication
so who wins well here's the reality
all four tools are very good and it's
really dependent on
your capabilities and the type of
environment that you're looking to
manage that will determine which of
these four
tools you should use the tools
themselves are open source so go out and
experiment with them
there's a lot of videos our team has
done a ton
of videos on these tools and so feel
free to
find out other tools that we have then
covered so you can learn
very quickly how to use them but
consider
the requirements that you have and
consider the capabilities of your team
if you have ruby developers or you have
someone on your team that knows ruby
your ability to choose a broader set of
tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding
then you may want to consider yaml based
tools
again the final answer is going to be up
to you and we'll be
really interested on what your decision
is
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more hi guys welcome to this
video on the interview questions of
configuration management tools
chef ansible and puppet chef is a
configuration management tool
written in ruby and erlang which
provides continuous deployment
increases system robustness and provides
cloud integration
ansible is another open source software
tool for provisioning configuration
management
and application deployment and puppet
is a configuration management tool that
can also be used as a deployment tool
and implements infrastructure as a code
in this video
we have compiled the most important
interview questions of configuration
management tools
chef ansible and puppet that you might
face in a devops interview
so without further ado let's get started
so let's just get into the first section
which is configuration
management so one of the questions that
you'll get asked right away is why do
you have ssl
certificates used for chef really
fundamentally your immediate answer
should be security
ssl provides for a very high level of
private security and
private and public key pairing this
really is essential to ensure that you
have a secure environment throughout
your entire network the second part
should be that if you're using ssl
and you're using the private public key
model within ssl
you're able to guarantee the systems on
your network that
the chef that you'll be able to validate
that the
nodes within your network that chef is
validating against
actually are the real nodes themselves
not imposters
so you will also be asked um some
questions such as the following which is
the following commands would you use to
stop or disable the http service
when the system boots and you'll
typically get four
responses and there'll be system ctl
disable httpd.service or is it
dot systemdisablehttp.com system disable
httpd or the final option which is
system ctl disable
httpd.service your answer should be the
first one which is hashtag system
ctl disable http dot service
so chef comes with a series of tools
that allows to function
effectively and one of the tools that
you're going to be asked about
is what is test kitchen and test kitchen
is essentially a command line tool that
allows you to be able to
test out your cookbook before you
actually deploy it to a real note so
some of the
commands that you would use are for
instance if you want to create an
instance of test kitchen you would do
kitchen create if you want to destroy an
instance after you created it you do
kitchen destroy
and if you want to be able to combine
multiple instances
you would do kitchen converge so a
question you'll get
is around chef is how does chef apply
differ from chef
client so fundamentally the difference
between them is that chef apply
will validate the recipe that you're
working on
whereas chef client looks to apply and
validate the entire cookbook that's run
in your server environment so one is
focused on
the recipe and the other is focused on
the entire cookbook
so there are some differences when
you're working with different command
lines
so for instance when you're working with
puppets and you're working with
one version of puppets and you want to
do what is the command to sign a
requested certificate
the top example here is for public
version 2.7
whereas the lower option here is for
puppet version
3. now something to bear in mind when
you're going through your interview
process
is that the tools that are used within
a continuous integration continuous
delivery devops
model do vary and so you want to be able
to talk
knowledgeably about the different
versions of the tools
so that when you're talking to your
interviewer you're able to show
the deep knowledge that you have which
open source or community tools do you
use to make puppet more powerful and
essentially this question is going to be
asking you to look beyond the core
foundation of puppet itself
and so the three options you have is uh
being able to track configurations with
jira which you should be doing anyway
but it's a great way to be able to
clearly communicate
the work that's being done with puppet
our version control
can be extended with get and then the
changes
should be passed through jenkins so the
three tools you want to be looking at
integration with jira git and jenkins
so what are the resources in puppet well
fundamentally there are
four the resources are basic unit of
any configuration management tool they
are the features of the nodes
they are the written catalog and the
execution of the catalog on a node so as
we dig deeper into puppet
one of the things that you are likely to
be asked regarding puppet is
what is a class and puppet and so a
class in puppet is really the name
blocks in your manifest
that contain the various configurations
and this can
include services files and packages
and we have on the screen here an
example of what a class would
look like when you write it out and you
may want to memorize
just one class don't memorize just a
whole set of classes
just memorize one the person that's
interviewing you is just really looking
for someone who has a working knowledge
they're not looking for you to have
memorized
complete massive classes but having one
small class to be able to illustrate
the experience you have is extremely
valuable to the interviewer
particularly if it's a technical
interview so as we move into
ansible one of the things that you're
going to be asked around ansible is what
is ansible role so a role is
an independent block of tasks and
variable files and templates
embedded with inside of the playbook so
example we have here on the screen
actually shows you one role within a
playbook and in this role it is to
install
tomcat on a node again as with
previous question within puppet of a
class it's probably good to have
memorized just one or two
roles so you can talk knowledgeably
about ansible
when you're having your interview so
when you're working with ansible
when should you be using the curly
brackets and so
just as a frame of reference there's
often two different ways
that these kind of brackets are referred
to now they're either referred to as
french brackets or curly brackets
either way and what you'll be wanting to
answer is
when would you use these specific types
of brackets
within ansible and really the answer
comes down to two things one is that it
makes it easier to distinguish
strings and undefined variables and the
second
is for putting together conditional
statements when you are actually using
variables and the example we have here
is this prints the value of and we have
foo
and we have to then put in the variable
conditional statement of
vu is defined as something so what is
the best way to make content reusable
and
redistributable with ansible and there's
really essentially three the first is to
include
a sub module or another file in your
playbook the second
is to import an improvement of an
include which ensures that a file is
added only once
and then the third is rows to manage the
tasks within the
playbook so a question you will be asked
is provide
a differences between ansible and
puppets
so if we look at ansible it's a very
easy agentless installation it's based
on python
you can configure it with yaml and there
are no support for windows
in contrast puppet is an agent-based
installation
it's written in ruby the configuration
files are written in dsl
and it has support on all popular
operating systems
so we dig deeper into the actual
architecture ansible it has a much more
simple architecture and it's definitely
a
push only architecture in contrast to
puppet it's a more complicated but more
sophisticated architecture where you're
able to
have a complete environment managed by
the puppet architecture
with this we have come to the end of
this puppet full course video
we hope that you guys have found it
informative and helpful
do like and share it thanks for watching
and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here